it's not my pleasure to introduce dr.
Larry PR in the 12th president of
hillsdale college president Arn received
his PhD in government from the claremont
graduate school and also studied at the
London School of Economics and at
werster College Oxford University while
at Oxford he served as director of
research for sir martin gilbert the
official biographer of Winston Churchill
president Arn is on the board of
directors of the Heritage Foundation the
Henry salvatori center of Claremont
McKenna College Americans against
discrimination and preferences the
Center for individual rights and the
claremont institute he is a member of
the american political science
association the mount paran society the
International Churchill society and the
philanthropy round table dr. Arnn and
his wife Penny have four children Katie
Henry Alice and Tony please join me in
welcoming dr.
good morning everybody welcome 50th and
60th reunion class you guys look young
I'm not just flattering you next year
the chairman of the board it's going to
be 50 looks a lot older than you guys do
and Dave Pringle right there if you see
lightning in a movie he makes it and so
it's kind of fashionable isn't it
there's some civilians up there who are
you guys are prospective students as I
do that is and your parents and your
admitted students or are you something
else admitted and so you're trying to
find out where you're going to go so I
wouldn't come here and that I'm a little
disgruntled with the senior class this
year because god there's a lot of them
so the college is too big we don't need
you and then o'sullivan back there I I'm
saying this for the faculty members who
have him in class there's imminent
danger that he's going to become the
sixth person in 25 years to get a four
point somebody fixed that would you but
you see what it means what I just said
this place is hard I'm not sure you want
to undertake this welcome yeah it is
hard I mean it it's also fun but it's
hard
I finished my senior dinner pinion I
finished our senior dinners last night
in our house and I want to give you a
quick report last year it was hard to
top because kody summer is capable of
playing the tap tap dancing and playing
the fiddle at the same time and he
claims incapable of doing them
separately and so that was a wonderful
act but last night there was a rival
because Tim Allen a member of the best
student band I've ever heard pickled
beets and he's in some other one that's
playing at central hall pollution says
it's good too but we'll see so he wanted
to sing two songs last night with his
guitar he can't sing very well and so he
asked me to choose between Mack the
Knife and fly me to the moon and I said
well it's got to be fly me to the moon
because mack the knife is a story about
a german murderer and at night and so my
senior class a wonderful group several
of these top ten their last night and
they cried out for the murder song
so I'm not sure we're good for these
kids I thank you senior class for what
you brought to the College it's precious
and good there's a lot of achievement in
this bunch blu-ray is going to Oxford
and UVA gave her the best scholarship
they got and then they because she's
going to Oxford they put it off for two
years he can keep it come later to uva
so she's going to cover herself in glory
and garrn yup professor gone yups tells
me last night that she won some national
championship in Latin or Greek Joe Latin
Greek and it's all Greek to me and and I
can't figure out about Bailey lindner
because she's higher up on the list and
Garrett West who's very high and somehow
she's sweet on him and I can't get to
the bottom of that it shows charity in
the senior class doesn't we've had a
good year this year we're going to have
a surplus admissions is active and
energetic and it's a large increase in
the number of applicants and we already
have too many so as I say we don't need
you so we hope that that will continue
and grow and get stronger yet we got
plenty of problems of course seems like
every year now some old and and
well-known liberal arts college closes
the ones that remain open don't really
do what we do anymore that's what you
have to understand there's some things
to know if you know them they'll make
your life they're the greatest things
there are to learn them as hard the
purpose of liberal education is to teach
those things we can't teach them to you
you have to learn them it's harder to do
that than almost anywhere else you could
go just because to address yourself to
all of that it's a
monumental thing and I've been having
these dinners and we got another one
still to come with these seniors and
they all come up to me and they'll say
my life is better and different because
of this and it is shocking an amazing
thing that that is decaying and being
abandoned nearly everywhere indeed it
turns now to the place where the
question is will it be legal to continue
to do that or will there be requirements
the people young people these seniors
those up there thinking of coming but
they have to be treated like factors of
production that the reason we spend
money on them is so that they can make
us rich and benefit us they're not ends
to themselves anymore most places I mean
among the best people at all places they
still are but by and large in most
places isn't it true that you're taught
at the same time that you should study
whatever you want to study because
you're the center of the universe but
also at the same time that there's got
to be a standard set of evaluations for
every college so we can compete with
China in the next century I never seen
that so impressive it is impressive as
it is right now finds its way into
regulation affects what we do here in
some ways makes me value what we do here
more than anything because it is so
precious we get to know each other we
get to do these things together that can
only be done together we have the
freedom to do that what we do radiates
everywhere now in the country all over
the place people know what Hillsdale
College is they think it of it as kind
of a remaining hope I get that
everywhere I go and the reason is is
because of everybody in this room right
now
we have the privilege to do that and the
responsibilities it comes from that
privilege I've been telling these
seniors you're not to forget that you
all the things you could you you've done
the rest of your life you have to give
it and you up there come here for love
it will reward you beyond anything that
could possibly happen and if you can't
come for that don't come hope you do
okay the daughtry award is given in the
spring for a senior faculty member in
the fall for a junior the list of those
who perceived it a very honorable and
Noble list is in your program the dot
reward comes from an anonymous gift from
Susan mcneir her grandmother was Emily
Daughtry and Susan did not want her name
mentioned but darn she thought of this
whole thing she thunk the whole thing up
and she did it by the way by coming here
and sitting in classes and going to
convocation and so she funded this thing
and so I'm just following her orders in
every respect but one she's done what
her name said this semester's recipient
is a touching person and touching that
she should receive this now she
graduated from Hillsdale College in 1971
three years before John savini did that
which means I think she's probably the
longest serving person on the campus
right now she got her master's degree in
72 and she came immediately to work here
and then she finished her PhD both of
those degrees at the University of
Michigan in 1980 she was promoted
associate in 84
and she was promoted professor in 80 in
91 and she's been chair of the modern
language department since nineteen now
she was chair from 1986 to 2002 and she
still chair French isn't that true if
not i hereby appoint her that and the
terrible thing is she's retiring this
year also will Marcy and Ryan Zeller are
retiring and dance on doll has retired
so those are all Grievous blows and this
is a bad one because you know I love
Ryan and I love well but they're not
nearly as nice as Ellen and and she's uh
she is the pro she is she gives rise to
generations of young people who
mentioned that her name to me years
later as having been important to them
and made them better that's her legacy
it's too bad that it's coming to an end
her teaching here but I may tempt her
back a lot because I'm certainly going
to try please congratulate dr. Ellen
justice Templeton
so it might have been Blackstock who
thought up this part of it if not it was
Susan mcnear but the department gets
some money because they were afraid the
department would be jealous that the
professor got some money and we have
internal controls at the college so I
can't give the money to the chairman of
the department because she's you know
doing both jobs here so Marie Claire
more like in the French department is
going to receive that and you get this
lovely certificate congratulations
I always forget that that fortunate man
right there is Jean Ellen's husband okay
our speaker today is uh how long has he
been here he's actually three hundred
and twenty-five years old now he he's au
beurre and he was last year's professor
of the year he is one of the best here
he was Provost when I came here and so I
know him really well I disappointed him
in so many ways and one of them is I
stopped sending out the Turtles he loves
chocolate turtles I mean he's insane for
them he it was like a ceremony when he
gave me my box of chocolate turtles with
the encouragement that I make them the
annual college gift to the donors and I
haven't done that but do I get I I mean
to give you Turtles from time to time do
I I give him Turtles yeah so that's his
way right he loves snow he loves skiing
he loved boats he loves to fall through
the ice into frigid water and almost
died he's a lawyer where'd he go to law
school did you go to law school Bob oh
yeah
do we pronounce it pet it or is the is
it the petty school of law can you tell
i like this guy he taught me about
college probably more than anybody else
because what do I know about college
except by doing it because I never did
did it before I came here and that his
way is very well known to me and much
admired he's a nice man he's tough
plenty tough but like if you're going to
do something that's really stupid there
between him and waylon is Waylan will
say you know that's really stupid
where's what black [ __ ] will say well so
we'll think about that he'll say and I
came to understand what that meant it
meant that we weren't going to think
about it he's a he's married to Jackies
Jackie here today she should be yeah
there she is and he's got Thomas and
Chris and Sarah and they're all
beautiful children they're all very
successful Tilda I was hearing about it
and that Thomas and Chris looked like
blackstock's and sarah has bright red
hair and so she was raised by her two
older brothers thinking for a long time
that she had been brought by aliens and
then she got too old to believe that
anymore so they persuaded her for some
years that she was adopted but that
mother and father didn't want to talk
about it
I give you the professor of the year
Robert black stop
thank you for that generous introduction
all true president iron dr. Whelan
esteemed Dean's distinguished visitors
visiting class of class of that fifteen
sixty years ago beloved students and
colleagues good morning it's pleasure to
be with you I'm honored I will tell you
this has been humbling and it's
manifestly unjust that the graduated
seniors who gave me access to this
podium are not here today to endure my
remarks leaving you I think only that
fading hope that I'll be brief which I
will try to be and what about you
seniors are all decked out to graduate
as if we're going to let that bad thing
happen an educated mind be holds a
universe proclaimed petrarch
embellishing perhaps on the the dictum
of the more famous words by seneca and
of course suggesting that the educated
mind sees things that the undeveloped
mind does not that as we look out on the
chaos that is life the developed mind
sees patterns sees realities and
relationships that the undeveloped mind
simply cannot see for instance while the
ancients looked upon the starry heavens
and silently random movement of the
stars and planets some eventually came
to see patterns and the means of gluten
on navigating the globe well 19th
century surgeons saw only rising death
tolls some eventually came to see the
need for sterile surgery while many
today see only random mountains of
market data some see strategies to
protecting assets and making them grow
and while some see only the chaos that
is human activity others see the Prince
of freedom and prosperity there are at
least three insights we can take from
Patrick's dictum one that each
generation needs to be educated anew
that insights gained in one generation
can be lost in the next and that a
complex mind needs not only fullness but
balance and proportion among the parts
permit me a few words about forgotten
insights and it's not that we've
completely forgotten them of course it's
rather that our generation in these
examples I think has come to not take
them seriously anymore for instance
earlier generations understood I think
fuller more fully than we do the nature
and the importance of our bifurcated
character that because we are created in
the image of God we're capable of great
good but because we are fallen we're
also capable of great evil and that
policy that understates our basic
goodness unnecessarily limits our
freedom and the ability of good people
to do good things and the policy that
understates our capacity for evil leaves
us vulnerable to that evil that is ever
at our side and within and earlier
generations understood more clearly than
ours that our fate and our future is in
very large measure determined by our
character our characters individuals our
character as a nation and that character
must be built and that people of sound
character can be counted on to take
whatever life throws at them and make
the best of it and the people of unsound
character can't be counted on for much
of anything and our forebears understood
not only that character must be built
but the primary builder of character
is the family so you ask what why do I
belabor these these points well consider
this for a broad swath of American
people the family is in a state of
collapse if you're not familiar with
this data yet research the percentage of
babies born last year to young
uneducated single mothers and the
relationship of that to poverty and know
that not too many years ago the recount
less organizations in the united states
that took it as one of their high
purposes to build character churches
virtually all schools private and public
countless civic organizations all took
it as a high purpose to build character
many of those organizations no longer
exist and those that do are having an
increasingly difficult time pursuing
that high purpose that that part of
their mission think here of the Boy
Scouts and not for the reason you're
probably thinking but because you have
here a civic organization that's trying
to do a hard thing in a culture that's
lost interest in the project building
character and consider the economic
collapse of 2008 the thing was entirely
self-inflicted and think for a minute of
all the greed and corruption high and
low note the arrogance the imprudence in
the hubris find if you can a hint of
prudence in a 30 year federal policy
that required banks to make loans to
people who in all probability would not
be able to repay those loans and recall
to that leading up to that collapse we'd
reinstituted the mark-to-market rule
that it had such a devastating effect on
the collapse of 1980 it appears we
cannot be taught
the collapse of 2008 was produced by
people of withered character and was
made possible only by a view of human
nature that earlier generations would
have found laughable and I think earlier
generations had greater faith faith in
God faith and universal principles right
and wrong and faith it with hard work we
can be better people than we are they
understood that without a firm and
reliable sense of right and wrong we
will be governed increasingly by a
Nietzschean will to power but enough of
this let's turn to the what's actually
primary point of my remarks and that's
that universe promised by Petrarch that
that full mind that can can perceive
that universe let us seek that full
universe let us pull back those blinders
and embrace it inner scholar now
endeavour take that course in Victorian
literature or vertebrate zoology or an
economic history of the United States or
the history of the Middle East or the
Far East do yourself a favor and take
that one hour seminar in personal
finance oh and with all those robots
nipping at your heels maybe something in
psychology or philosophy wouldn't be a
bad idea either and commit not only to
the contemplative life but to the act of
life and to wholeness studies show the
commitment is the primary determinant
not only of ethical conduct but have
sound marriages and yes that new year's
resolution to get in shape and repellent
though it may seem embrace that wider
world and all of its flaws and please do
fix those broken policies and those
flaws but keep in mind and just be
warned that my generation leaves you a
mess but as you embrace that wider world
remember to keep those many and growing
parts of your mind balanced and in
proportion and especially cherish and
guard those things that are closest to
you and which brings so much meaning to
all
what you do for me of course the stars
with a knowing and loving touch of my
beautiful wife to whom I owe so much
cherish your families remember this you
will never hear anyone say gee I wish it
hadn't invested so much myself and my
family you will never hear anyone say
that you'll also never hear anyone say
gee but you take my point and and guard
your faith ours is a season of
questioning and and rising unbelief but
know that there have been seasons of
unbelief before ours and there will be
others after and remember that the leap
of faith to unbelief is at least as
great as the leap to belief and keep in
mind the beauty and the grace and the
strength and comfort that reside in
thoughtful and humble faith and cherish
this community for the beautiful thing
that it is the shared search for truth
and excellence and for beauty and the
good the striving the flaws and the
failings the friendships the honesty and
humility the forgiveness the love the
compassion the humor and so you ask how
many philosophers does it take to change
a light bulb well it takes two one to
change the light bulb the other to
research what Aristotle had to say about
changing light bulbs I'd like to close
with a few lines from Wendell Berry
professor Barrie is a professor of
English and in his spare time a farmer
and as I read these lines I want you to
keep in mind that he knows full well
that we need to embrace that wider world
that there are for instance right now
bad people out there planning to do us
harm and they have to be dealt with but
as we come to grips with that wider
world let us not lose sight of those
things that bring meaning and purpose to
life
professor barry rights this is a book
about heaven but i must say to that it
has been a close call for I've wonders
sometimes if it would not finally turn
out to be a book about Hell where we
fail to love one another for reasons all
to abundantly provided or for
righteousness sake or for pleasure where
we destroy the things we need the most
where we see no hope and have no faith
where we must lose everything to know
what we have had but as Jaybirds life
transpires he sees more each day that
hope provides for him and for those
around him and to realize with john
dryden that love this loves reward thank
you